66 votos a favor 49 en contra y seis
abstenciones señores congresistas ha
sido aprobada la reconciliación a la
votación del texto sustitutorio El
Congreso peruano aprobó así reconsiderar
la votación del proyecto de reforma
constitucional que permitiría el
adelanto de los comicios generales a
octubre de 2023 Pese a que el pasado
viernes un desacreditado legislativo
rechazó por amplia mayoría esta
propuesta en un intercambio de
apelaciones la críticada presidenta Dina
boluarte pidió al congreso la suma su
responsabilidad histórica y responda al
grito de las miles de personas que
continúan saliendo a las calles de todo
el país voten por el Perú a favor del
país
adelantando las elecciones al 2023 y
digámosle al Perú entero con la más alta
responsabilidad que nos vamos todos el
consejo permanente de la organización de
los Estados Americanos aprobó una
declaración sobre los hechos que se
están sucediendo en Perú la oea mostró
su preocupación por las denuncias sobre
el uso excesivo de la fuerza y la
represión por parte de los uniformados
para callar el estallido social haciendo
un llamado a las autoridades peruanas
para la realización de elecciones
generales uno de los principales pedidos
de los manifestantes su firma llamado a
las autoridades peruanas para que
aseguren la gobernabilidad e
institucionalidad democrática mediante
la pronta realización de elecciones
generales justas libres y transparentes
con observación electoral internacional
la convocatoria de elecciones se antoja
como una de las principales vías para
desescalar la crisis política y social
que vive la nación andina desde
diciembre cuando la destitución del ex
mandatario Pedro Castillo o de un
intento fallido de golpe de estado sacó
a las calles a miles de peruanos